if it doesn't have a face if it never
had a face would you eat it my name is
Sarah and I'm a video producer here at
BuzzFeed and I just found out about
lab-grown meat so if you're like me
you're thinking wait what is that what
is it called is it like real meat quick
explainer lab-grown meat is actual meat
but they didn't slaughter an animal to
get it yes i cloned meat or something
it's originally from like an animal cell
right so they have to get something from
an animal to then grow stem cells are
taken from an animal and then they're
grown in a culture the cells multiply
until they become muscle tissue this
looks like somebody's getting pregnant
that muscle tissue is what forms meat
some of this sounds very cool and sci-fi
right but what are the benefits of
lab-grown
according to the UN meat consumption is
expected to rise as much as 73 percent
by 2050 we have like a huge global food
problem and so you know if it helps
solve that then awesome growing mean
labs could reduce greenhouse gases by
96% compared to traditional livestock
farms are all the benefits from
lab-grown meat enough to convince a
vegetarian or vegan to try it I was
raised without any red meat or pork so I
think it would make me pretty sick my
stomach would immediately reject it and
I would just vomit so probably not don't
want to eat meat anyway whether it's
like from an animal or grown in a lab I
don't think I'm I stopped eating meat
because of the cruelty I miss chicken
I miss cheese I miss all these things I
just my stomach can't tolerate it
anymore I think it's taking something
from them that we don't need to take
away and like why do we need to take a
animal cell to then grow a burger if we
have so many plant-based options for a
lot of vegetarians and vegans it doesn't
matter it's lab-grown meat they're not
interested in meat period but for the
meat eaters there are also some concerns
I would probably try lab-grown meat it's
a little bit weird I would try it once
you know because I think I would try
everything once but I guess it's no
weirder than eating like an actual
animal look you cook it I'll eat it the
fact that we animals is a little weird
anyway because they're too
like they're not that different from
people why do I eat meat if I knew that
it was grown in a lab I would still eat
it
I have no standards when it comes to
food I would be down as long as they
could prove it's not a carcinogen as
long as like 30 years from now people
aren't growing arms out of their heads
or something
it depends on how expensive it is I
wouldn't pay more money to eat food that
was grown in a lab just because it
didn't kill any animals I'm I'm broke
yeah lab-grown meat it sounds pretty
fancy it has to be expensive right like
how much does it cost
the current hamburger has costed 250,000
euro which is quite a lot dr. marcoh
slab ground hamburger cost three hundred
thirty one thousand dollars to produce
in 2013 but the prices had gone down
substantially in the past few years and
by 2023 dr. mark post hopes then you'll
be buying my up grilled meat at
supermarket prices it tastes good and it
looks like they're doing it responsibly
I have no problems with it hell yeah I'd
eat lab-grown meat that sounds a dope
meats delicious everyone knows that
unless you're not into me there is quite
some flavor with the Browning and I know
there's no fat in it so I didn't really
know how it's how juicy it will be
lambreaux me lacks the fat from
traditional livestock so unless you're
super into lean meat the taste might not
be your thing but there's quite some
intense taste it's close to meat it's
not that juicy the good news is that
scientists are experimenting on ways to
add healthy fats into lab-grown meat so
you can get that juicy taste you desire
juice it taste but the bottom line is if
I walked up to you with a hamburger that
was made out of lab-grown meat would you
try it man if this lab-grown meat thing
works out and be very exciting I mean I
let her one earth one people so people I
make it in a lab
Wow that's true what was your question